Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
When we, humans look at an image, or a piece
of video footage, we understand the geometry
of the objects in there so well, that if we
have the time and patience, we could draw
a depth map that describes the distance of
each object from the camera.
This goes without saying.
However, what does not go without saying,
is that if we could teach computers to do
the same, we could do incredible things.
For instance, this learning-based technique
creates real-time defocus effects for virtual
reality and computer games, and this one performs
this Ken Burns effect in 3D, or in other words,
zoom and pan around in a photograph, but,
with a beautiful twist, because in the meantime,
it also reveals the depth of the image.
With this data, we can even try to teach self-driving
cars about depth perception to enhance their
ability to navigate around safely.
However, if you look here, you see two key
problems: one, it is a little blurry, and
there are lots of fine details that it couldn’t
resolve, and, it is flickering.
In other words, there are abrupt changes from
one image to the next one, which shouldn’t
be there as the objects in the video feed
are moving smoothly.
Smooth motion should mean smooth depth maps,
and it is getting there, but it still is not
the case here.
So, I wonder, if we could teach a machine
to perform this task better?
And more importantly, what new wondrous things
can we do if we pull this off?
This new technique is called Consistent Video
Depth Estimation, and it promises smooth and
detailed depth maps that are of much higher
quality than what previous works offer.
And, now, hold on to your papers, because
finally, these maps contain enough detail
to open up the possibility of adding new objects
to the scene, or even flood the room with
water, or add many other, really cool video
effects.
All of these will take the geometry of the
existing real-world objects, for instance,
cats into consideration.
Very cool!
The reason why we need such a consistent technique
to pull this off, is because if we have this
flickering in time that we’ve seen here,
then, the depth of different objects suddenly
bounces around over time, even for a stationary
object.
This means, that in one frame, the ball would
be in front of the person, when in the next
one, it would suddenly think that it has to
put the ball behind them, and then, in the
next one, front again, creating a not only
jarring, but quite unconvincing animation.
What is really remarkable is that due to the
consistency of the technique, none of that
happens here.
Love it!
Here are some more results where you can see
that the outlines of the objects in the depth
map are really crisp, and follow the changes
really well over time.
The snowing example here is one of my favorites,
and it is really convincing.
However, there are still a few spots where
we can find some visual artifacts.
For instance, as the subject is waving, there
is lots of fine, high-frequency data around
the fingers there, and if you look at the
region behind the head closely, you find some
more issues, or you can find that some balls
are flickering on the table as we move the
camera around.
Compare that to previous methods that could
not do nearly as good as this, and now, we
have something that is quite satisfactory.
I can only imagine how good this will get
to more papers down the line.
And for the meantime, we’ll be able to run
these amazing effects even without having
a real depth camera.
What a
time
to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!